Hello?
First things first.
Check your e-mail.
I got one.
Fake Dylan at W.H.O.
This is the WHO’s real domain, right?
W.H.O. dot I.N.T.
So Fake Dylan is a internet security researcher
that I worked with to send all of our emails
a bunch of fake messages.
And he was able to send these messages from
the real W.H.O. domain.
I'm going to say I'm coming to you from my
new job in the World Health Organization.
I spent all my money moving to Geneva, Switzerland.
Please, send me some bitcoin to tide me over?
It might say “this is a joke” in our example
here, but the more serious ones would be like,
“there's an urgent new coronavirus warning
from the W.H.O.”
As the number of coronavirus cases increases,
so too do Internet scams and hoaxes.
Real-looking emails supposedly from the World
Health Organization and CDC asking for money.
These agencies do not ask for direct donations
by e-mail.
If you click on a link or download an attachment
from those e-mails, you could be giving hackers
your personal information.
So what we're looking at here is domain spoofing
and we're seeing it a lot with respect to
the coronavirus in particular.
So this really has been totally unprecedented.
The teams have never seen anything like this
in terms of a single lure, uniting all different
types of actors behind a single real pretext
for people to do all kinds of things, whether
it's actually just steal their password, what
we call credential phishing, whether it's
install malware.
So this is just one example sent from what
looks like the W.H.O. e-mail address, just
like the one that came to you.
Clearly it's trying to get you to download
a specific file that they have sent.
And researchers at IBM found that that file
contains malware that captures screenshots
and logs your keystrokes and steals usernames
and passwords.
Huh, “beware of criminals pretending to
be W.H.O.”
The W.H.O. has actually published guidance
on this and they are aware that this is happening.
But its top advice, its number one advice,
is: “Verify the sender by checking their
email address.”
We know that that’s pretty easy to fake
at this point.
Wow.
I'm surprised they don't point that out because
people might think that if it has a W.H.O.
dot I.N.T address, that means it's legitimate.
But really, it's a necessary but not sufficient
condition.
Correct.
Yeah.
What I found super interesting was that we
tried spoofing a bunch of domains, and only
some of them went through to the inbox.
The CDC and Vox emails didn’t, but WHO and
Whitehouse.gov emails did.
And I should say, it was only the Yahoo emails
that we set up.
The Gmail and Outlook emails both put them
in spam.
So I've been looking into this and it seems
like the greater context around this is that
when email was created back in the eighties,
no one bothered to make any way to verify
that the sender is who they say they are.
Really it is the foundational technologies
of the Internet being built with no security
in mind and no central database of who is
who that gives rise to this problem.
And since then, there've been lots of attempts
to sort of build this sort of verification
system.
The problem is just that the participation
is not as high as it should be.
So of make sense of this, it might help to
think about another type of verification problem,
which is that society doesn't want teenagers
to get into bars to buy alcohol.
To prevent that from happening, we need two
things: We need a way to verify ages, which
is our ID system, and we need businesses to
then check for IDs.
Now, imagine if that ID system was voluntary.
So you have a bunch of adults who might not
bother to go get an ID.
Then when they come to the bar, the business
basically has a decision to make.
Either they require IDs knowing full well
that plenty of legitimate adults don't have
one.
Or, to avoid pissing people off, they just
let them in and maybe they end up letting
in some kids too.
And probably every bar is going to make a
slightly different decision.
That's kind of where we're at.
With email authentication right now.
We have an I.D. system.
It's called DMARC, but it's voluntary.
So if an e-mail comes in with my email address,
joss@vox.com, the email service, whether that's
Yahoo! or Outlook or G-mail, is going to check
if that domain, Vox.com, has a DMARC record.
And we do!
Thankfully, Vox took the time to set up a
DMARC record, which basically does three things:
First, it says that the email has to come
from a certain set of IP addresses that Vox
trusts.
Second, it says that the email has to carry
a unique signature that only Vox can create.
And third, it says that if the email fails
either of those two tests, then the email
service receiving the email should reject
it, should just throw it away so that it never
reaches anybody's inbox.
Because of that, my Vox e-mail address, your
Vox e-mail address, we can't be easily impersonated.
OK, so say an e-mail comes in from a domain
that doesn't have a DMARC record or has set
their DMARC policy to something other than
“reject,” that e-mail is going to have
a higher chance of getting through.
Now, the e-mail providers all have spam filters.
They have these algorithms that are looking
through these emails to check and see if anything's
fishy.
But obviously that didn't stop Dylan's fake
e-mail from getting into my Yahoo! inbox.
I would guess that the W.H.O. does not have
a strong DMARC policy set up, if they have
one at all.
OK, there's actually a way that we can double
check this.
Oh, nice.
It has this nice little green box that comes
up.
But this is the actual DMARC record.
V equals DMARC1, P equals reject.
So this is telling us that our policy is,
“reject this e-mail.”
And this is true, I think, of… yeah, the
CDC as well.
What about the White House?
Yeah.
Let me try the White House…
Huh.
OK.
So the White House has published a DMARC record,
but if you look at it, P equals none, meaning
that they are not telling email providers
to reject e-mails that come from other IP
addresses or that generally are not from their
approved domain senders.
The weird thing about that…
So this is their guidance on what all federal
agencies are supposed to do.
“All agencies are required to, within one
year after issuance of this directive, set
a DMARC policy of reject for all second level
domains and mail-sending hosts.”
Wow.
So the White House is violating its own policy.
At the very least, they’re acknowledging
that a DMARC policy of reject is the strongest
protection.
And it is very clear that they are not using
that protection.
So now let's try the W.H.O.
“Not protected against impersonation attacks!”
They have not published a DMARC record at
all.
And I can understand.
Like the W.H.O. has a lot on their hands right
now.
They're basically leading the global effort
against this giant pandemic.
But damn, it really seems like they should
have done this.
Yeah.
And to be fair, it’s not like the WHO is
alone in this.
There’s a report by ValiMail, that shows
that less than 15 percent of domains with
DMARC have actually set their policy to reject
spoofed emails or send them to spam.
There's kind of an incentive issue at play,
which is that you publish the record to protect
other people from being phished.
And the tradeoff there is that if you don't
configure it properly, and it does take some
work to set up correctly, you risk some of
your e-mails not being delivered.
I think that the W.H.O. is in a tough spot
right now because it is incredibly important
in this moment that their e-mails get through.
And also there's an increase in the risk that
it's coming from a fake domain and that, you
know, maybe they have some more responsibility
than they might have before in terms of protecting
people from fake e-mails.
Hey, do it for us, because we're all, you
know, vulnerable out here on the internet
looking for information.
Yeah.
It is the sort of thing that every good citizen
of the internet should do.
But, you know, like eating your vegetables
and working out every day, it's not something
that every organization does.